.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
* Krächzender, unsauberer Ton *
Das kommt schon.
Klingt gut.
* Krächzender, unsauberer Ton *
* Krächzende, unsaubere Töne *
Das ist schon fast eine Melodie.
Die Region wird auch
der Wilde Westen Luzerns genannt.
Ich bin unterwegs nach Sörenberg, in
der sog. UNESCO Biosphäre Entlebuch,
und folge dem Auftrag
von Bundesrat Ueli Maurer.
Machen Sie Ferien in der Schweiz,
geben Sie das Geld hier aus!
Besuchen Sie die Naturschönheiten,
treiben Sie Sport,
geniessen Sie das Essen,
den Wein, das Bier, das Wasser!
Wohl noch nie haben
so viele Schweizerinnen und Schweizer
die Sommerferien
im eigenen Land verbracht.
So hat man es sich vorgestellt:
"Machen Sie Ferien in der Schweiz."
Mich interessiert, was dieser Aufruf
der Tourismusbranche gebracht hat.
Meine Schweizreise
beginne ich mit einem Alphornkurs.
Sind Sie ...
- Reichlin. - Herr Reichlin.
Sind Sie beim Alphornkurs mit dabei?
- Wir sind dort oben, ja.
So.
Ich habe schon lange
keine Hand mehr geschüttelt.
Hallo, freut mich.
Adrian.
- Hallo.
Zwei, drei Dinge vorneweg:
Es ist ein Fortgeschrittenenkurs.
- Gibt es keine Anfängergruppe?
Nein. - Ich dachte,
es gäbe auch eine Anfängergruppe.
* Idyllische Alphornklänge *
Die Kursleiter
blasen zum Start der Ferienwoche.
Für mich heisst es vorerst: zuhören.
Ganz herzlich willkommen
in der Biosphäre.
Es freut uns riesig,
dass Sie trotz Corona
und trotz schwieriger Situation
diese Woche bei uns sind.
Mein Name ist Wolfgang Kuchler.
Ich komme aus der Region Stuttgart,
man hört es vielleicht.
Ich bin ein totaler Anfänger, aber
das Programm hat mich angesprochen.
Ich lebe seit 1973 in der Schweiz
und betreibe seit 1983 ein
Sternerestaurant im Kanton Thurgau.
Kennt jemand den Thurgau?
Der Kanton
liegt zwischen Konstanz und Zürich.
Ich habe mich riesig gefreut,
herzukommen.
Ein Alphorn besitze ich
schon seit zehn Jahren.
Während der Krise
habe ich es ausgepackt und versucht,
ein paar Töne rauszubringen.
Deswegen bin ich heute da.
Danke vielmals.
Während die Ferien-Kursteilnehmer
loslegen, muss ich noch trocken üben.
* Unsauberer Ton *
Einatmen.
* Harmonische Alphornklänge *
Gut.
Darf ich dich etwas fragen?
- Ja.
Du arbeitest in einem Reisebüro?
- Ja, genau.
Wie läuft es?
Nicht wirklich ...
Ja, es ist nicht so toll.
Im Moment ist es wirklich nicht
sehr lustig mit dieser Ungewissheit.
Die Leute, die reisen wollen,
können nicht reisen,
weil die Flüge annulliert werden.
Es ist sehr schwierig.
Hat der Kurs hier
etwas damit zu tun?
Ich musste meine Ferien streichen,
konnte nicht verreisen.
Jetzt habe ich Ferien
und kann die ganze Woche
Alphorn spielen.
Inwiefern
kann man sich hier entspannen,
wenn man beruflich
so unter Druck ist?
Ich hoffe, dass ich mich
zuweilen entspannen kann.
So, hierher.
Also ...
* Blasübungen *
Wie eine Biene.
Genau.
Das klingt gar nicht so schlecht.
Das ist unser erster Ton.
* Sauberer Ton *
Probier mal, den nachzumachen.
* Unsaubere Töne *
Genau.
Das ist schon sehr gut.
Das kommt gut.
- Okay.
Wie lange dauert es, bis man ...
Das ist wirklich individuell.
Aber nach dem
zweitägigen Schnupperkurs
kann wirklich jeder Teilnehmer
eine Melodie spielen.
Echt? - Ja.
In zwei Tagen lernt man viel.
Wie erleben Sie den Corona-Sommer?
Als Musiker ist es schwierig,
weil sämtliche Auftritte
abgesagt werden.
Die Menschen haben Respekt.
Niemand traut sich,
eine Veranstaltung durchzuführen.
Bei solchen Kursen,
die draussen stattfinden,
merkt man, dass die Menschen
sofort dabei sind.
Wir sehen das auch
an den Teilnehmerzahlen.
Hast du das Gefühl,
es ist eine Chance für das Entlebuch?
Ja, momentan schon.
Der Thurgauer Gourmetkoch
Wolfgang Kuchler
transportiert sein Alphorn
standesgemäss.
Passt ein Alphorn zu einem Porsche?
Sehr gut sogar.
Achtung, da sind ein paar Kuhfladen.
- Ja, genau.
Sie sind schon ausgetrocknet.
Welches Mundstück nehmen wir heute?
Ich nehme die 18.
- Ich die 22.
Das ist eigentlich für einen Bass.
- Aha, eben.
Aber das ist gut.
Du hast auch volle Lippen.
Ich bin eben ein Grossmaul.
* Idyllische Alphornklänge *
Was bringt dir das?
Dass ich mich selbst höre.
Sonst hört man sich ja nicht.
Dann hat man plötzlich das Gefühl,
man sei gut.
Statt Alphornspielen
hätte man hier im Entlebuch
auch Gold waschen können
oder Steinböcke beobachten.
Und vieles mehr.
Bei der Recherche zu meiner
Schweizreise war es schwierig,
aus der Vielzahl der Angebote
etwas auszuwählen.
Die Schweizer Ferienregionen haben
sich mit Imagekampagnen überboten
und insgesamt Millionen investiert.
Schau, endlich kommen sie
wieder nach Graubünden.
Hier hat eben
auch jeder genügend Platz.
Komm zu uns in die Ruhe der Natur.
Komm, wie du bist -
diesen Sommer im Wallis.
So, haben wir alles?
Im Entlebuch bin ich unterwegs mit
dem Direktor der UNESCO Biosphäre.
Theo Schnider
ist seit vier Jahrzehnten
ein wichtiger Tourismustreiber
in der Region.
Er kritisiert
die landesweiten Imagekampagnen
und den Marketingaktivismus
im Corona-Sommer.
Alle Kantone
machen praktisch das Gleiche,
selbst Österreich
lancierte eine richtige Kampagne.
Ob das die Leute noch anspricht,
ist fraglich.
Man müsste mehr
in die Produkte investieren.
Das hätte den Vorteil, dass man sich
langfristig ausrichten würde.
Momentan ist es eine Feuerwehrübung,
weil das Thema aktuell ist
und man das Gefühl hat,
man müsse etwas unternehmen.
So steht man unter Zwang
und kann nicht gestalten.
Zentrales Thema in der Biosphäre
Entlebuch sind die Moorlandschaften.
Diese gelten seit einer Initiative
vor über 30 Jahren als geschützt.
Damals ging die Angst um,
der Moorschutz
könnte die touristische Entwicklung
der Region verhindern.
Inzwischen werden die Moore
aber erfolgreich vermarktet.
Theo Schnider
ist auch Verwaltungsratspräsident
der Bergbahnen Sörenberg.
Nach dem Stillstand im Frühling habe
man hier im Sommer mächtig aufgeholt.
Die Zahlen für den Juli: 20 % mehr
Frequenz und Umsatz als im Vorjahr.
Und auch für die Hotels sei es
ein ausgezeichneter Monat gewesen.
Was meinen Sie,
wie nachhaltig ist das?
Oft heisst es, es gebe
eine Vor- und ein Nach-Corona-Zeit.
Ist die positive Tendenz nachhaltig,
oder ist das eine Eintagsfliege?
Der Mensch neigt dazu, möglichst
schnell wieder zu vergessen.
Ich glaube, so nachhaltig ...
Es wird einen Einfluss haben.
Es ist wichtig,
dass man das Angebot so gestaltet,
dass man die Werte,
die jetzt gefragt sind, aufnimmt
und versucht, sie umzusetzen,
damit sie Bestand haben,
überleben können.
Welche Werte sind das?
Man sollte vermehrt
den Menschen ins Zentrum rücken,
die Natur, regionale Produkte
und die ganze Entschleunigung.
Aber gerade hier in Luzern hat man
mit der Stadt einen Tourismusort,
über den sogar viele Einheimische
sagen, es sei zu viel.
Ja.
Was meinen Sie,
wird sich das ändern?
Ich bezweifle,
dass eine Stadt wie Luzern,
die sehr stark auf den
asiatischen Raum gesetzt hat,
sich plötzlich ändern
und sich fortan auf Schweizer Gäste
ausrichten kann.
Stimmt das Produkt überhaupt noch?
Mit dem Asienmarkt
hat sich auch das Konsumverhalten,
das Angebot in der Stadt
ein wenig geändert.
Die Stadt
ist sehr stark ausgerichtet
auf den Verkauf von Uhren,
Schokolade und Souvenirs.
Und jetzt soll der Schweizer Gast
das plötzlich kompensieren?
Den interessieren Uhren,
Schokolade und Souvenirs nicht.
Das muss einem zu denken geben.
Man muss vielleicht Strukturen,
die intakt waren
und dem Massentourismus
geopfert wurden,
wieder zurückgewinnen.
* Treibende Klänge *
Auf der Sörenberger Rossweid
findet sich das sog. Mooraculum.
Was das Entlebuch ausmacht,
Moor und Natur,
solle hier für Kinder
zum Erlebnis werden.
Guten Tag.
Schweizer Fernsehen,
dürfen wir eine Frage stellen?
Ja, das dürfen Sie gerne.
Wie geht's?
- Merci. Es geht gut.
Woher kommen Sie?
- Aus Norddeutschland.
Ehrlich?
- Ja.
Die Familie ist aus Norddeutschland.
Ich lebe und arbeite in der Schweiz,
in Münsingen bei Bern.
Jetzt sind wir
auf einem Tagesausflug in Sörenberg.
Wir wollen uns das mal anschauen.
War das so geplant?
- Das war so geplant, ja.
Keine Ferien im Süden?
- Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Es ist so angenehm und schön
in der Schweiz.
Wieso hier?
Die Arbeitskollegen
machten mich darauf aufmerksam.
Jetzt sind wir
mit den kleinen Kindern hergefahren
und gucken uns das an.
* Idyllische Klänge *
Die Alphorn-Ferientruppe
zu Besuch in einer
Traditionswerkstatt im Emmental.
Was vielleicht nicht alle wissen:
Das Alphorn ist der Vorgänger
des Mobiltelefons.
* Lachen *
Die Hirten haben sich
vom einen zum anderen Hügel
Nachrichten zugespielt.
Man hört ein Alphorn bis 10 km weit.
Schon über drei Generationen
betreiben dieses Kunsthandwerk.
Bestellst du eines?
Ja, schreib meinen Namen auf:
Wolfgang.
Mir ist völlig egal,
wie viel es kostet.
Ist gut. Das machen wir gerne.
Dann hat sich dein heutiger Vortrag
schon gelohnt.
Das ist wie ein Porsche, nicht?
Das ist der Porsche
unter den Alphörnern.
Zwischen 3'500 und 5'000 Fr.
wird das Alphorn wohl kosten.
Passiert es oft, dass jemand ein Alp-
horn gleich mitnimmt oder bestellt?
Ab und zu gibt es Bestellungen,
mitnehmen kann man nichts.
Wir machen alles auf Bestellung.
Wie lange dauert
die Herstellung eines Alphorns?
Acht bis zehn Monate.
Wie läuft es im Corona-Sommer?
Es ist eine schwierige Zeit.
Sehr viele Menschen sind ängstlich.
Anfangs wusste man auch nicht,
wie man sich mit Blasinstrumenten
verhalten muss.
Viele haben sofort abgesagt,
gingen gar nicht mehr aus.
Hast du das gelesen, Bruno?
"Ausgebucht".
Der Höhepunkt für die Amateurbläser:
das Konzert im Kemmeriboden.
Oben.
* Idyllische Alphornklänge *
Es ist wie eine Parallelwelt.
Die Welt des Reisebüros
ist sehr, sehr hart,
und dieser Kurs ist echt toll.
Hier sind gute Leute,
man hat Ablenkung,
aber das andere
holt einen immer wieder ein.
Was war denn genau?
Acht Büros wurden geschlossen.
Am Hauptsitz
wurde viel Personal abgebaut.
Insgesamt 70 Mitarbeitende
müssen gehen.
Und in Ihrem Büro?
Da wurde eine Person entlassen.
Das mussten Sie ihr heute mitteilen?
- Ja.
Corona fährt in diesem Sommer
irgendwie überall mit.
Ich verlasse die Zentralschweiz
und fahre nach Baselland.
Dieser Halbkanton hat mich mit seiner
Sommer-Werbekampagne überrascht.
"Das Ferne liegt so nah!"
"Spektakulär wie die Gondeln in Rio -
aber direkt vor der Haustür."
Baselland so "altehrwürdig
wie das Kolosseum in Rom" ...
... oder so "majestätisch
wie der Kilimandscharo".
Das wollte ich
mit eigenen Augen sehen.
Irgendwo hier muss es sein.
Anfang Juli in Liestal.
Baselland ist nicht
für seinen Tourismus bekannt.
Bei der Mehrheit der jährlich
knapp 300'000 Logiernächte
handelt es sich um Geschäftsreisende.
Doch diese Übernachtungen gingen im
ersten Halbjahr um über 50 % zurück.
Jetzt setzt man
auf Schweizer Feriengäste.
Salut ...
Jetzt habe ich es selbst vergessen.
Der Ellbogen ist schon blau.
Ich war gestern in der Innerschweiz.
Da begrüsste man sich mit der Hand.
Baselland soll
auf die Tourismuskarte der Schweiz.
Das ist das Ziel von Michael Kumli,
der hier im Mai,
mitten in der Corona-Krise,
als Geschäftsführer begann.
Davor war er beim Triathlonverband.
Selber ist man ja immer
etwas bescheiden und zurückhaltend.
Man lebt halt im Baselbiet.
Beim Triathlonverband,
im Haus des Sports,
hatte ich einen guten Draht
zu den anderen Geschäftsführern.
Als ich sagte,
dass ich ins Baselbiet wechsle,
sagte der vom Schwimmverband:
"Willst du Kirschbäume vermarkten?"
Als ich ihm dann zeigte, was wir
alles haben, war er erstaunt.
Da sich die Leute momentan
über die Schweiz informieren,
ist es wirklich eine Chance,
dass man uns wahrnimmt.
Ich mache mich auf den Weg
zur Gondelbahn Wasserfallen,
die mir in der Werbung wie diejenige
in Rio de Janeiro angepriesen wurde.
Schau mal, ein Einweiser.
Full house.
Gut.
Da herrscht aber viel Betrieb.
Er nützt jeden Zentimeter aus.
Ist es bis zum Abend voll?
Es sollte schon um 12 Uhr voll sein.
Und wenn man zu spät kommt?
Man darf heute bei der Kirche
und beim Schulhaus parkieren.
Wurde zu viel Werbung gemacht?
In der aktuellen Situation
ist alles etwas anders.
Im letzten Jahr war es nicht so.
Eine Fahrt mit der Gondelbahn
von Reigoldswil nach Wasserfallen
war im Juli so populär
wie noch nie in einem Sommer.
18'000 Fahrten - ein neuer Rekord.
Rund 6'000 mehr als im Vorjahr.
Da sind ja die Kirschbäume.
Baselbieter Kirschbäume
statt brasilianischer Zuckerhut –
auch schön.
Guten Tag.
- Guten Tag.
Drinnen oder draussen?
- Draussen.
Sonne oder Schatten?
Das ist eigentlich egal.
Dann dürfen Sie gerne
die Hände desinfizieren
und innen durchgehen -
es ist Tisch Nummer 111.
Sie nehmen es aber ziemlich streng.
Wir müssen die Leute
etwas zurechtweisen.
Es ist nicht alles erlaubt.
Einige Gäste werden auch wütend
und gehen wieder.
Aber wir können es nicht ändern.
Einige gehen deswegen?
Ja, sie haben das Gefühl:
"Nein, so nicht. Das ist zu viel."
Wie erleben Sie es so?
Schwankend.
Es fehlen natürlich die Gruppen,
die Carunternehmen.
Geburtstags- und Hochzeitsfeste
finden auch nicht statt.
Nur der À-la-carte-Bereich
ist offen.
Da sind wir sehr eingeschränkt
mit wenigen Sitzplätzen.
Einen Monat später
wird mir Frau Huber sagen,
es sei schlussendlich
ein erfolgreicher Sommer geworden.
Beliebte Restaurants
in Berg- und Seeregionen
hätten im Sommer
erfreuliche Resultate erzielt,
meldet der Branchenverband
GastroSuisse.
Aber das sei nur ein kleiner Teil.
Gesamtschweizerisch
sieht es düster aus.
Der Juli-Umsatz im Gastgewerbe war
rund 32 % tiefer als letztes Jahr.
Am meisten
litten die Betriebe in den Städten.
Guten Tag.
Woher sind Sie?
- Aus der Normandie.
Unsere Tochter
hatte die schlechte Idee,
einen Schweizer kennenzulernen.
Fühlen Sie sich sicher
in der Schweiz -
ich meine wegen des Virus und so?
Nun, wir sind schon
recht vorsichtig geworden.
Die letzten Monate
haben doch Spuren hinterlassen.
Wir meiden Orte mit vielen Leuten,
z.B. Autobahn-Raststätten.
Viele Gewohnheiten
müssen wir ändern.
Wir passen uns an.
Und die Begrüssungsküsse?
Das ist vorbei.
Oben auf dem Chellenchöpfli
mit der prächtigen Aussicht
herrscht reger Betrieb.
Kann ich hier durch,
ist das okay?
Ja, kommen Sie. Geht es?
- Ja, es muss.
Wir müssen langsam Abstand halten
bei so vielen Leuten.
Bleiben Sie nur. Das war Spass.
Das war ein Witz.
Einen solchen Ansturm an Autos
habe man hier im Sommer
noch kaum je gesehen.
Diese Bilder
von der Anreise nach Zermatt
habe ich von einem
einheimischen Hotelier erhalten.
Da macht es mehr Sinn,
mit dem Zug nach Zermatt zu reisen.
Der Autoverkehr
hat laut Walliser Medien im Juli
um bis zu 20 %
gegenüber dem Vorjahr zugenommen,
der öffentliche Verkehr im Kanton
ging um rund 20 % zurück.
Im internationalen Hotspot Zermatt
hatte man dem Sommer
mit Sorge entgegengesehen.
Im Sommer sind hier die ausländischen
Touristen meist in der Mehrheit,
insbesondere solche
aus Asien, Amerika oder der EU.
Aber dieses Jahr sind es v.a.
die Schweizerinnen und Schweizer,
die in Massen
in den Walliser Ferienort reisen.
Es ist voll, wir müssen stehen.
Oft allerdings nur als Tagesausflug.
Hallo!
Eine Fahrt mit der Zahnradbahn
auf den Gornergrat.
Die Bahn wurde im Jahre 1898 eröffnet
und führt auf über 3'000 m ü.M.
Ich steige
bei der Station Rotenboden aus.
Luft, Luft.
Wo ist dein Cowboyhut?
- Den liess ich zu Hause.
Per Zufall treffe ich hier
auf das Hotelier-Ehepaar
Gerlinde und Art Furrer.
Ihn hatte ich erst kürzlich
in einem Film porträtiert.
Wie geht's?
- Tipptopp.
Es hat unglaublich viele Leute.
Aber die kommen am Morgen
und gehen am Abend.
Unglaublich viele Leute ...
- Aber v.a. Tagesausflügler.
Der Parkplatz,
auf dem früher die Busse standen,
ist voll besetzt mit privaten Autos.
Die Leute kommen nicht mehr
mit dem Zug, sondern mit dem Auto.
Wegen der Maske.
Ich trage sie auch nicht gerne.
Ja, das ist mühsam.
Aber wenn wir jetzt nicht aufpassen,
werden wir das noch bereuen.
Hier am Riffelsee
fotografieren meistens Asiaten,
Araber oder Amerikaner.
Diesen Sommer
sind es v.a. die Schweizer.
Wir haben an Auffahrt entschieden,
in der Schweiz zu bleiben.
Wir sind sehr glücklich,
erstmals in Zermatt zu sein.
Wir haben die Chance genutzt,
ein Stück Schweiz kennenzulernen.
Mach noch ein Pose.
Yeah.
Was müsste man noch besser machen,
damit mehr Schweizer
im eigenen Land bleiben?
Ich muss ehrlich sagen:
Die Schweiz ist teuer.
Mein Mann hat kein Halbtax.
Und ohne Halbtax kosten diese Bahnen
ein halbes Vermögen.
Wir kochen auch immer selbst.
Ein Hotel in der Schweiz
ist für uns keine Option.
Bei Zermatt Tourismus heisst es,
der Ort
biete für fast jedes Budget etwas.
Zurück im Dorf.
Ich bin unterwegs zu einem Mann,
der Gäste beherbergt,
bei denen Geld
weniger eine Rolle spielt.
Schon schön.
Ein Hotel mit grosser Geschichte.
Hier im Fünfsternehotel Mont Cervin
Palace treffe ich André Seiler.
Er führt die Seiler Hotels
schon in der fünften Generation.
Er sagt, diesen Sommer seien
fast 90 % seiner Gäste Schweizer.
Das ist eine gute Sache.
Viele Gäste sind sicher
das erste Mal hier in Zermatt.
Ich denke, das sind Besucher,
die später wiederkommen werden.
Warum sind Sie so optimistisch?
Ich glaube, die Berge
haben eine gute Zukunft im Sommer,
auch wegen der grossen Hitze
im Flachland.
Bergwanderungen sind populär,
auch Touren mit den E-Bikes.
Die Zukunft von Zermatt
ist eher im Sommer.
Im Winter können wir hier nicht mehr
viel zusätzlich rausholen.
Trotz der Schweizer Gäste:
Das zweite Seiler Hotel,
das legendäre Monte Rosa,
bleibt diesen Sommer geschlossen.
Die Betriebskosten
wären höher als die Einnahmen.
Im Normalbetrieb
sieht es hier so aus.
Berühmtheiten wie Marlon Brando
oder Winston Churchill
waren hier schon zu Gast.
Hier servieren wir normalerweise
am späteren Nachmittag den Tee.
Die Leute erholen sich.
Es gibt viele Stammgäste,
die sich kennen.
Einige seiner Mitarbeiter
sind auf Kurzarbeit.
Je nach Entwicklung
werde er im Winter
weniger Saisonverträge abschliessen
als früher.
In Sachen Wintersaison wissen wir
wirklich noch nicht, wo es hingeht.
Welche Länder öffnen sich?
Die Probleme
mit der Quarantäne und alles -
viele Gäste haben Angst,
irgendwo stecken zu bleiben.
Sie warten ab, was im Oktober
und November geschieht,
bevor sie ihre Buchungen bestätigen.
In Zermatt rechnet man aufs ganze
Jahr mit einem Logiernächte-Rückgang
von bis zu 40 %.
Das wären
über 800'000 Übernachtungen weniger.
Den Corona-Sommer
mit wenig ausländischen Touristen
konnte das erfolgsverwöhnte Zermatt
offenbar gut wegstecken.
Aber sollten die ausländischen Gäste
auch im Winter noch fehlen,
wäre das für die Tourismusanbieter
hier ein schwerer Schlag.
Kämpft ihr mit voller Kraft?
Ich würde sagen mit 60-70 %.
Er hat sich schon
die Lippen geschürft.
Ich bekam zwei Schläge auf die Hand,
aber mit dem Holzschwert.
* Kommandos auf Latein *
Fortis cadere.
- (Alle) Cedere non potest.
Baselland, Anfang August -
einen Monat
nach meinem ersten Besuch.
Das ist grosses Kino.
Hier
bei der Römerstadt Augusta Raurica
hätte diesen Monat das grosse
Römerfest stattfinden sollen,
mit über 20'000 Zuschauern.
Jetzt gibt es nur eine Miniversion.
* Kampfgeschrei *
* Jubel *
Der Sieger: Tirius.
Der Verlierer: Priscus.
Nimm deinen Helm ab!
Was ist nun?
Soll er leben oder sterben?
* Verschiedene Zurufe *
Die Mehrheit will Priscus behalten.
Danke schön.
Damit ihr wisst, was passiert wäre,
wenn ihr euch
für seinen Tod entschieden hättet:
Es war eine sehr zeremonielle,
rituelle Art,
wie der Gladiator gestorben ist.
Wie ist Ihr Eindruck?
Genial gemacht.
Respekt, dass sie das
in dieser Hitze durchgezogen haben.
Mit den Helmen.
- Es ist heiss, nicht?
Wie das früher
zu- und hergegangen ist ...
Die Familie Petitti
aus dem Kanton Glarus
hat vor dem Besuch der Römerstadt
eine Nacht in Baselland verbracht.
Genau solche Gäste hätten sich
die Tourismusverantwortlichen hier
öfters gewünscht.
* Hornsignal *
In linea, venite!
Wie zufrieden bist du
mit der Sommersaison -
jetzt, da die Ferien vorbei sind?
Ich bin zufrieden,
aber es gibt viel Potenzial.
Die Hoffnung war,
dass die Leute hier übernachten.
Wie sieht es diesbezüglich aus?
- Durchzogen.
Wenn man die verschiedenen Bereiche
im Tourismus betrachtet:
Die Restaurantbetriebe
laufen sehr gut.
Das Feedback ist gut bis sehr gut.
Mit einzelnen Freizeitaktivität
sind die Leute
trotz Einschränkungen zufrieden.
Überhaupt nicht zufriedenstellend
sind die Übernachtungszahlen.
Wieso sind Leute
nicht hierhergekommen?
Die Angebotsvielfalt in der Schweiz
ist riesig.
Die Ausgangslage hat sich
plötzlich komplett verändert.
Für alle stand plötzlich
der Schweizer Gast im Zentrum.
Bis vor Kurzem
war das noch etwas anders:
Man hat sich
auf das Ausland fokussiert.
Wir sind halt
immer noch nicht der Klassiker.
Schweizweit fällt die Bilanz der
Hotelübernachtungen für diesen Sommer
insgesamt ernüchternd aus.
Der Ansturm der Schweizer
auf die Berggebiete
konnte das Fehlen ausländischer Gäste
nicht wettmachen.
Im Vergleich zum Vorjahr
waren es im Sommer
über 3 Mio. Übernachtungen weniger,
ein Minus von 27 %.
Wir verabschieden uns.
Wir gönnen uns jetzt ein Eis
und verziehen uns in den Schatten.
Immerhin: Der Sommer
wird als Zeit in Erinnerung bleiben,
in der viele von uns
ihr Land neu erlebt
und besser kennengelernt haben.
Dieser Wert
lässt sich nicht in Zahlen messen.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Philipp Schlatter - 2020